المترجم: Dalia Nour Eldeen
المدقّق: Riyad Almubarak
منذ زمن، حينما كنت صغيرًا جدًا.
لم يكن هناك إنترنت
ولا يوتيوب ولا منصات تواصل اجتماعي.
ولم يكن هناك كل الوسائل المتاحة حاليًا،
التي يمكن أن ترى أو تشاهد بها الأشياء.
لذلك كنا نعتمد بشكل كبير
على الراديو والتليفزيون،
كان الراديو بالنسبة لي مبهرًا جدًا،
كنت أستمع إلى المسلسلات
الموجودة في الراديو، والأشياء القديمة،
الأشياء القديمة التي لا يستمع
لها صغار العمر، كنت في المرحلة الإعدادية.
لم أكن أستمع إلى الأغاني وكل هذه الأشياء،
كان تركيزي في كيفية عمل هذه المسلسلات،
كان هناك روايات عالمية تتحول لمسلسلات،
كان هناك مسلسلات ألف ليلة وليلة،
أكثر شيء أبهرني في هذه المسلسلات
هو المؤثرات الصوتية.
عن كيف يجعل هذا المؤثر الشخص يرى شيء
خارج من سماعة راديو صغير في المنزل.
كان هذا شيء مبهر بالنسبة لي وأردت أن أعرف
كيف فعل الشخص المختص هذا الشيء،
كيف جعلني أرى مياه أو سماء،
كيف جعلني أرى أي شيء من هذه الأشياء.
وبعد ذلك بفترة، قررت
أنه لابد أن أعرف كيف يحدث ذلك.
سأوضح لكم ذلك بأكثر من شيء
يوضح ما أقوله أكثر.
(موج بحر)
ما سمعناه هو صوت موج البحر.
لن ترى كثيرًا في موج البحر سوى ثلاثة أشياء
السماء والبحر والرمل.
لأنه صوت موج بحر فقط بدون أي شيء آخر
لأنه لم يعطك أي شيء آخر لترى صورة مختلفة.
فهذا أقرب شيء يفترض أنكم رأيتموه الآن.
(موج بحر)
هذا بحر مجرد بدون أشخاص أو شكل
أو أي شيء معين ولا تعرف مكانه،
لأن كل هذا غير متواجد في الصوت الذي سمعته.
ولكن إذا أردنا أن نغيّر المكان بصوت أيضًا،
كيف نفعل ذلك؟
(طيور وموج بحر)
حسنًا، ما حدث الآن
هو أننا رأينا شيئًا إضافيًا بجانب البحر.
صوت البحر موجود وهناك أيضًا صوت طيور،
وعند وضع صوت الطيور فإن معظم الناس
يرون الشجر لأن كليهما مرتبط ببعضهما البعض.
فالبنسبة إليك، أنت ترى بحر وتسمع صوت طيور،
فأنت ترى شيئًا مثل هذا.
(طيور وموج بحر)
هذا أقرب شيء رأيناه.
لأننا تخيّلنا البحر موجود من الصوت
كذلك الطيور والشجر شيء موجود.
كل هذا يحدث تلقائيًا، فأنا لم أقرر
أنني أسمع صوت طيور إذا أنا أرى شجر،
أو أنني سمعت صوت كذا، إذًا أنا أرى كذا
ولكن المخ يفعل ذلك بشكل تلقائي لأن هناك
مرجع مسبق به،
يربط هذا الصوت بهذا الصوت
وهذا الصوت بهذا الصوت،
وبقوم برسم هذا الشكل في دماغي.
نريد أن نغيّر هذا المكان بصوت سريع، كل
هذا وصوت البحر ثابت ولكن نغيّر مكانه فقط.
(أصوات متداخلة)
اختلف الوضع الآن قليلًا، كل البحر الفارغ
أو الذى بجانبه شجر أو جزيرة اختفى الآن.
ورأيت شاطىء عادي، أطفال تضحك وأشخاص
موجودة على الشاطيء تصيف وكل شيء.
فهذا هو أقرب شيء رأيناه.
(أصوات متداخلة)
كل هذا حدث بمجرد وجود ضجيج أشخاص،
هذا الضجيج غير واضح به كلام أشخاص
أو اللغة التي يتحدثون بها،
سواء كانت اللغة العربية
أو اللغة الإنجليزية أو غيرها،
أنت فقط تتخيل شاطىء مزدحم،
لذلك كل شخص يتخيله لأقرب شيء إليه.
الأشخاص الذين يصيفون في الساحل
سوف يرون شاطىء الساحل،
كذلك من يصيفون في السخنة، سوف يرون السخنة،
الأشخاص الذين يسافرون إلى الخارج،
سوف يرون هذا الشاطىء في بلد في الخارج.
ولا يزال كل هذا بدون مكان معين،
لم يحدد البحر بلد معين أو شاطىء معين،
كل هذا غير موجود في الصوت، لأن
الصوت مجرد من المعلومة التي بها المكان.
سوف نضيف شيئًا ونرى أين يمكن أن يكون.
(أطفال وموسيقى)
غالبًا سوف نتخيل أن هذا شاطئ في اليونان.
لأن هناك موسيقى، وهى موسيقى يونانية،
لذلك سوف يخطر ببالك أنه في اليونان.
لكن لأنه يوجد لدينا في مصر
شكل أقوى من اليونان،
لذلك أعتقد أن معظم الأشخاص المتواجدين هنا،
تخيلوا هذا الشكل.
(أطفال وموسيقى)
حزلقوم بالنسبة لنا أقوى من اليونان
ومن الموسيقى ومن كل شيء.
لأن هذا المشهد حينما كان في الفيلم،
كان من أهم المشاهد الموجودة في الفيلم.
لذلك أصبحت الموسيقى اليونانية
مرتبطة بحزلقوم وهو نازل على البحر
وهم يخبرونه أنه في مكانٍ ما
وهو ليس في هذا المكان.
لذلك، نراه جميعًا وهو واقف ينظر، والناس
يجرون والسيدة التي تأكل محشي وكل ذلك.
هذه هو قوة الصوت،
الصوت يبتكر شيئًا في دماغك،
أقرب شيء موجود عندك، أنت من تقوم بتخيله.
أنا فقط قمت بوضع الموسيقى،
ولكنك أنت من تخيلت.
أنا أعمل في الراديو منذ 13 عام.
ومنذ بداية عملي وحتى الآن
يعد الصوت بالنسبة لي شيء مهم جدًا.
ليس الصوت أن نقوم بتشغيل الموسيقى
أو صوت برامج أو أيًا كان،
ولكن فكرة ما يحركه الصوت نفسه في الشخص.
الحياة من حولنا أو أكثر شيء
نجرب به الحياة هو الصوت.
إذا كنت تسير في الشارع
وسمعت صوت ميكروباص
وهناك رجل يقول رمسيس رمسيس،
أنا لست بحاجة أن أنظر وأرى ميكروباص يسير،
وبه شخص نصفه خارج من الشباك
وهو ينادي على الناس.
إذا هناك صوت بوق مقطورة مرتفع،
وأنت تسير على الطريق الدائري
فإنك تلقائيًا تشاهد المقطورة تسير خلفك،
ولكن أحيانًا تنظر فتراه تاكسي أبيض
وأن السائق وضع ذلك فقط ليزعج به الناس.
لكني رأيت المقطورة للحظة،
قبل أن أنظر وأرى الشيء الحقيقي.
ومثال آخر أيضًا، إن كنت تسير وسمعت صوت
شمام دراجة نارية من نوع هارلي وصوت عال،
فتعتقد أنك ستنظر وترى شخص يرتدي خوذة
وجاكيت أسود ودراجة نارية أشاهد شكله،
ولكن تنظر فترى سيارة 27 الشكمان بها محطم،
وأخذها الميكانيكي كي يصلحها.
بالنسبة لك تشعر بالاندهاش رغم أنه لا يوجد
أي شيء يوضح لك صوت الدراجة النارية.
ولكن هذا أقرب شيء لي،
أقرب من الشكمان ومن أي شيء آخر.
هذه هي القوة التي تجعلك ترى هذه الأشياء.
لذلك الراديو قوي لأنه يستخدم الصوت،
وأنت من تبني هذا الصوت وليس أنا.
حينما أعطيك هذا المثال،
فأنا أعتمد على خيال الشخص
بأنه سيتخيله بأقرب شيء إليه.
لذلك هذه الأشياء من أنجح الأشياء الموجودة
لإن أنت من تفعلها، أنت من تخلق المشهد،
أنت من تخلق الشكل.
وهذا مهم لأن ذلك هو بصمتك في الصوت،
أو بصمتك في الشيء الذي تستقبله.
أنت لا تستقبل فقط
بل تضيف أيضًا عليها لتصبح لك.
يحب كل الناس أن يجعلوا أغراضهم شخصية،
الشخص الذي يشترى هاتف،
فور شرائه يقوم بتغيير نغمته،
وصورته الرئيسية وأماكن الأيقونات،
الكاميرا في مكانٍ ما والباقي في مكانٍ ما.
الذي يقوم بتأجير شقة، يقوم بدهن الحائط
لمجرد التغيير.
الذي يعمل في مكان يدخل ويضع شيء هنا
ويقوم بلزق شيء على الزجاج،
ليجعل هذا المكان ملكًا له
وليس ملك أي شخص آخر.
هذه هي رسالة الراديو
أو هذه هي قوة الصوت الموجودة في الراديو،
لأنك من تفعل ذلك وليس أي شخص آخر.
الراديو مجرد،
دعنا نقول أنه شيء مجرد قليلًا.
مجرد بمعنى أني أعطيك
شيئًا صغيرًا وأنت من تقوم ببناؤه.
أنا أقوم بتقليل كل شيء
ممكن أن أشرحه للشخص،
لأنه كلما قللت، كلما أعطيته القوة
بأن يفعلها بدلاً من أن أفعلها له وأفسدها.
لدينا مثال نشرح به أكثر،
لدينا مسلسل في الراديو منذ 13 عام،
واسم هذا المسلسل طنط دولت.
هذا المسلسل بطولة مذيعين اثنين،
يوسف الحسيني وكريم الحميدي.
كل شخص منهم يقوم بتمثيل دورين.
هذا المسلسل منذ 13 عام، وطوال الفترة
الماضية لم نذكر شكل أي شخصية من الأربعة.
لم نقل أبدًا إذا كان هذا المعلم طويل
أو قصير، سمين أو نحيف، بشعر طويل أو أصلع.
لم نقل أيضًا إذا كان يرتدي
ملابس عادية أو جلابية.
لم نقل حتى أين يسكنون
إلا حينما يكن لدينا سبب لتحريكهم،
ويحدث نفس الشيء في الثلاث
شخصيات الأساسية الآخرين.
لا يوجد شيء، غير معروف إذا كانت دولت
محجبة أو غير محجبة،
كذلك غير معروف إذا كانت سمينة أو نحيفة
ونفس الشيء عن سعدية،
وكذلك سوكا وهو الشخصية الرابعة.
هذا أيضًا مهم لأنه طوال الفترة الماضية
الناس من يتخيلون ذلك.
كل شخص لديه شخصية دولت في حياته،
على أنها السيدة الكبيرة في العمر
والتي لا تستمع لأحد وسليطة اللسان.
ودائمًا تشتم الناس والشخصية الثانية
خادمتها التي أصبحت تربطها بها علاقة صداقة.
كل شخص إذا أعطيته تفاصيل أكثر من ذلك،
فستقلل جزء خلق الشخصية الذي يفعله.
قوة الصوت أنه يفهمنا أشياء أخرى كثيرة.
مثلًا، قد تسمع حوار بين شخصين وأنت لا تفهم
شيئًا من الحوار إلا حينما تسمع صوت معين،
هذا الصوت قد يجعلك ترى الصورة.
سوف نستمع إلى الحوار التالي:
"سعدية، ركزي معي جيدًا، أنا سأطلق النيران
على كل الحرس الموجودين بالخارج،
وأنتِ سوف تهبطين من على هذا السلك،
لكن انتبهى من أن تجرحي قدميك.
لا تقلق عليًّ يا معلم، أنا مستعدة ومرتدية
القفازات والحذاء الأسود ذو الرقبة الطويلة
إذا أردتي أن تحدثيني في أي وقت،
اضغطي على هذا الزر،
سوف أسمعك، انتبهي لنفسك يا سوسو."
(صرخة)
"سأبدأ بالهبوط الآن،
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
أشهد أن لا اله الا الله
وأن محمد رسول الله،
بسم الله توكلنا على الله."
ما سمعناه هو حوار بين المعلم وسعديه،
وبه أكثر من شيء،
نحن لا نعلم أين هم وماذا يفعلون
ولا نعلم لما يصيحون،
ولا نعلم ما هذا الزر الذي ستضغط عليه،
ولا هذا السلك الذي ستهبط من عليه.
لماذا لا يوجد كل ذلك، لأن هذا يحدث
عندما يتم تسجيل الحوار لأول مرة.
لكي أفهم هذا الحوار ولماذا يصيحون
ويفعلون ذلك، أحاول أن أقلل مؤثرات الصوت،
ولكني سأضع مؤثر صوتي واحد
ثم نرى إذا وضح هذا المشهد أم لا.
(طائرة هليكوبتر)
"سعدية، ركزي معي جيدًا، أنا سأطلق النيران
على كل الحرس الموجود بالخارج،
وأنتِ سوف تهبطين من على هذا السلك،
لكن انتبهى من أن تجرحين قدميك.
لا تقلق عليَّ يا معلم، أنا مستعدة ومرتديه
القفازات والحذاء الأسود ذات الرقبة الطويلة
هيا، إذا أردتي أن تحدثيني في أي وقت،
اضغطي على هذا الزر،
سوف أسمعك، انتبهي لنفسك يا سوسو."
"سأبدأ بالهبوط الآن،
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
أشهد أن لا اله الا الله
وأن محمد رسول الله،
بسم الله، توكلنا على الله."
صوت واحد وهو صوت طيارة هليكوبتر جعلنا نرى
أشياء كثيرة لم نكن نراها.
علمنا لما يصيحون، ورأينا هذا الزر،
والذي ربما يكن زر السماعة
الموجودة في الهليكوبتر.
ورأينا السلك الذي تهبط من عليه سعدية
وتخيلنا حتى شكلها وهي تهبط رغم أن ذلك
غير موجود في الصوت ولكنها وصفته.
ورأينا المعلم وهو يقفز وكل هذه الأشياء.
كل هذا حينما أعرضه على المستمع أو المتلقي،
لابد وأن أقلل كل شيء.
وضعت فقط الهليكوبتر ولم أضع أي شيء آخر.
المخ هو الذي خلق هذه الصورة بأكملها،
بشكل الهليكوبتر الذي آراه.
شخص تخيلها سوداء وشخص تخيلها الهليكوبتر
الخاصة بالجيش المموهة،
وشخص آخر تخيلها صغيرة أو كبيرة،
كل هذا قوة الشخص المتلقي.
هذه أيضًا جيدة وعملت تحديات،
وحينما حاولنا تحويل
هذا المسلسل إلى كرتون مرسوم.
وأحضرنا رسام وطلبنا منه
رسم هاتين الشخصيتين وكيف تخيّل شكلهما.
سوف نرى المحاولات
التى حدثت لهاتين الشخصيتين.
هذا هو تصور لشخصية سعدية التي كانت تتحدث،
قد تكون الموجودة على اليمين
أو الموجوده على اليسار.
لكن أشخاص كثيرون
قالوا بأنها ولا واحدة من هؤلاء.
كثيرون تخيلوا سعدية بشخصية
موجودة في حياتهم يعرفونها،
بأنها سيدة جارتنا أو أنها سيدة تعمل
في منزل شخص معين،
أو سيدة تعمل في مكان معين،
كل هذا تخيلته.
وحينما طلبنا من الرسام رسم ذلك،
كان خياله محدود، أقل من خيال
كل هؤلاء المستمعين أو المتلقين.
وحينما طلبنا منه أيضًا رسم المعلم،
فرسم هذه الأشكال، هذا هو شكل المعلم
بالنسبة للفنان الذي رسم هذه الأشكال.
هو لا يرتدي جلابية وهو رفيع وليس سمين.
وهو يرتدي في الصورة التي على اليسار كاجوال
ولكن يرتدي على اليمين جاكيت وكرفته،
ولكنه أيضًا يرتدي الطاقية الفلاحي
التي يحبون ارتداءها.
هذه حددت شكل الشخصيتين
بالنسبة لنا وبالنسبة للناس.
ولكننا قررنا عدم فعل ذلك
لأن هذا سيقلل من خيال المستمع،
أو الشخص الذي يحب هذا المسلسل
ويستمع له منذ 13عام.
هذه هي قوة الراديو، الراديو قوي
وسيبقى على قيد الحياة من زمن وحتى الآن
رغم الأشياء الموجودة تحت الطلب
والتواصل الاجتماعي واليوتيوب والساوند كلاود
وكل وسائل الصوت الموجودة.
الراديو سيقى قوي لأنه الوحيد
الذي به جزء الخيال،
ويدفع الشخص للتفكير ورؤية كل هذه الأشياء.
والراديو لن يموت
طالما يتخيل الناس هذه الأشياء.
شكرًا.
(تصفيق)